the thing is every successful person you
know has failed at what they love to do
before
I've been unsuccessful in my career you
just didn't know about it because I
wasn't famous yet and I was trying to be
famous I was trying to get a record deal
for six years and I kept getting turned
down and any successful person you know
even though it seems like everything
just happened for them it usually was
preceded by a bunch of failure or at
least a significant amount but the great
ones aren't the ones that don't fail
they're the ones that learn from their
failure and they keep going and they're
persistent and they're tenacious and for
me I was trying to get a record deal for
from 98 to 2004 and got turned down by
every major leopard label including the
one I'm signed to now and for me that
means that even when you hear no you
have to keep going through all those
knows and take it to yes and with
learning something new I think it's the
same principle when I was younger I
didn't really know that you could just
get better at things because I think
we're so used to the idea that you're
talented at something and and it's sort
of fixed you know the idea that oh he's
just a good singer you know and even
with singing I've gotten better at
singing as I've gotten older I wasn't
singing in a way that was sustainable
and I wasn't breathing right I wasn't
doing a bunch of things correctly I
realized that there was a ceiling that I
couldn't crack through unless I actually
studied and worked under a coach to get
better and this idea that things are
just fixed is proven not to be the case
you can get better at things you can
grow and even people that are innately
talented still need to go beyond that
basic talent that they have and
cultivate it